e
yeah e
all right uh it's uh it's 10 o'clock I'm
going to convene uh today's working
session we are listening uh only to the
New Hampshire prescription drug
affordability board this morning um I
know that Mr White has other obligations
that started at 10:00 so so I'm I'm
going to I'm going to
Mr Williamson I'm I'm going to try to
frontload the kind of technical
questions we may have after you do your
presentation um so that um um Mr White
feels free to leave okay all right so um
with that would would you introduce
yourself to the committee and for the
clerk to put you in the record
absolutely um good morning everybody I'm
Kirk Williamson and I am the executive
director of the prescription drug
affordability board
oh go ahead and uh Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services okay so uh I
think everything on the prescription
drug affordability board is on page
1054 of the of the um the budget and the
uh request is 100% General funds uh in
the next fiscal year it's essentially
you know 256
5 um um th000 and then it goes up
slightly in the second year another
10,000 to
2656 so um so that's that but uh so my
my technical question is that in the
last
hb2 uh I think I don't I think directed
may be the right term we the the the we
directed that and account would be
established with the
pdab so that it was able to receive uh
Community donations to support its
operation and as I look at the the
budget on
1054 I I do not see a line item where
you're ready to accept donations could
could you could you speak to
that
sure so um chairman Edwards is is
referring to the the dedicated fund that
was created in
statute and the the prescription drug
affordability board accouny unit 6273
that is 100% General funds from a
funding source perspective there are no
other funds there
currently um I don't I if you want to so
so to just clarify that uh if if that
that means the dedicated fund is not yet
established because if it were it would
be a line item here or would it be a
line item somewhere
else class I think you call it a class
code 6273 would it fall under there so
the thing that I would just need to go
back and verify and take a closer look
at the statute is whether the accounting
unit that's sitting before you would be
considered part of that dedicated fund I
suspect that that would potentially be
different but if the intent was for the
other Revenue sources to fund the
operations then we would see those other
Revenue sources here and we may just
want to take a closer look at the
original
statutory uh language on that front all
right so so the intent of that uh uh in
hp2 last year was to establish a form of
other Revenue to associate with a
prescription drug affordability board so
that any Don ations received could be
used directly by uh the operations that
that that was the intent and I'm glad
you're going to relook the statute
because that but uh because because I
don't remember the statute but I did I
clearly remember the
intent absolutely and we we haven't been
approached with donations as of yet or
or that type of we haven't been
approached with any Revenue um the
original uh legislation did have us
funded through peas and assessments um
um like many other boards in the state
that shifted to 100% General funds and
we do have ideas that we'd like to talk
with you about chairman Edwards um that
we've been thinking about to be more
self- sustaining yeah um and it could be
an hb2 thing but yeah maybe we could
talk offline about that so so we can do
all of that I the my my goal here was
just to do the technical part of the
conversation so that Mr White could feel
free to to to go do the conflicting
things
and then we'll talk we'll
yeah uh represent I respect the the need
for Mr White to leave but I'm wondering
if the executive director can literally
give us a 45 second summary of what PAB
is for the members that were not part of
us last B I'm here to have that
conversation and knowledge we we we'll
have that I Mr White are you do you are
you preparing to say anything
further yes
so I'm I'm looking at the statute it's
it's under RSA 126
bb8 and it establishes the non-aps
fund um and it it it does it does
specify that the the board shall use the
the dollars consistent with the
provisions of of the statute but
um may be used to pay for administrative
technical legal support and other costs
incurred by the board so it's not
necessarily clear to me that the intent
there was to um supplant or replace the
accounting unit that you're seeing
within the governor's operating budget
in
6273 yeah the intent was to augment to
be a supplemental source so that we
we're not 100% relying on General funds
but that we could um that that without
us directing the spending of that of
those receipts that that would create
flexibility for for uh the board yep and
and so if uh as as Kirk was indicating
if if we were to receive any Revenue
then what we would do is we would go
through the standard process uh as
dictated by rsa1
1430a where we'd accept the dollars
through the fiscal committee and GNC and
then we would sub submit a memo to D or
D would go ahead and add those funds to
that account and then those could be
utilized but currently because um we
have no in that account you're not going
to see that show up here it's um it's
similar to I think a few other scenarios
where uh for R example from yesterday
with the uh maximum security unit where
because we don't have any history there
you're not actually seeing any account
show up because there's no revenue and
and to have an expense you need to have
Revenue right so okay so I I have been
thinking there we had a chicken and egg
situation that first we had to create
the account so that the uh board could
solicit uh or encourage donations that
that that it was a stepwise step one
establish the account to seek donations
but it's not that way it's actually the
opposite is what you're saying well
because because the account The
Authority for the account is already
established in state law uh what we
would do is just submit a memo to this
is one of the things you don't really
see here but we submit memos to D you
know for certain things and this would
be one of those things that would just
transpire once we money right so so the
takeaway from that is we've always been
able to or since that statute went into
effect we've always been able to accept
donations uh and based on the first
donation I think I donated a dollar
actually
um you know I don't know where it went
but I I don't I did not accept that
dollar you did not accept you offered me
one but I said I do not want to accept
this because I don't want to spend that
much time I I'm going to have to spend a
lot more money to accept the dollar then
it's going to be worth what's your break
even how much do I have to give you to
uh have you establish the account uh I
don't know uh think about it okay uh O
Okay so I think we've hit that one topic
and if you would like to excuse yourself
no I no one here would be offended I I I
I greatly appreciate that sorry good
yeah you're welcome to stay too I'm not
throwing you out okay all right thank
you so so with that transition um Mr
Williamson sorry Williamson um go ahead
and tell us everything you want us to
know okay okay um thank you thank you
Nathan for being here um so thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee um
again I'm Kirk Williamson and I'm the
executive director of the prescription
drug affordability board and I
appreciate the opportunity to speak
before you today about the critical role
we play in protecting New Hampshire
residents businesses and taxpayers from
The High Cost of prescription drugs I
know this is a very challenging area of
healthcare and just the issue RIT large
so if um if you have follow-up questions
or anything I'm happy to make myself
available to you whenever I can um so
just to level set with everybody the New
Hampshire prescription drug
affordability board analyzes
prescription drug costs and their impact
on public payers taxpayers and patients
and identifies cost-saving opportunities
and makes public policy recommendations
to the legislature
the board monitors market trends
promotes transparency and vises the
legislature and public payers on
strategies to balance affordability with
sustainable healthc care spending in a
short amount of time we have already
produced results um in our last report
we identified $6 million in potential
estimated savings if those negotiated
rates were applied to New Hampshire
Public state in local employee health
plans we would immediately see reduced
bending um we are formalizing a
recommendation for a state-backed
privacy first pharmacy savings card that
would be no cost to the state um it
launched two years ago in Connecticut as
for one example they are seeing an
average of $240 of savings per script
that comes to $1.23 million in savings
for the state shows that in the slide
deck that the breakdown on that 6
million I included the I included it in
our accomplishments um but I can follow
up with that information if that would
be helpful for you yeah I think this is
a a kind of a critical issue because um
uh I I I think you all have been
operating uh in statute for about four
and a half years and uh and and there's
been a tremendous amount of startup
investment made and I think we're on
you're on I I should for disclosure let
people know I'm I'm a member of the
prescription drug affordability board I
think I think the board is on the cusp
of being able to produce things um and I
want to talk about the forward-looking
part of how we're investing to get a
return on investment so so the the idea
that we've already had a return uh I
think we need to understand
that sure um and so we were established
in 2002 I was hired last year so the
board has been staffed with one
full-time employee for for a little over
a year um and and to your point laying
the foundation does take a lot of work a
lot of investment there is rulle making
data sharing agreements getting the
analytical processes in place um we now
have those data sharing agreements in
place we are analyzing and tracking
prescription drug spending over time we
are identifying areas of cost-saving
opportunities we are in the process of
formalizing a recommendation and working
with the governor on this prescription
drug discount card but we can only make
recommendations that be very clear we
don't have enforcement Authority we
can't do anything about the price
necessarily but we can make
recommendations and assist public payers
and assist the leg legislature to that
effect sure so just so you know what my
frame of mind is on this is that I I I
do agree that there's been a period of
time where we've had to ramp up and
create a capability and I don't actually
I didn't actually expect uh that your
presentation would include any uh
specifics on um Financial benefits of
the past what I really was thinking we
would do today is talk prospectively on
how this new money in this budget would
be
leveraged for you know what we can
expect from it so so the fact that
you've got six million already right I
want to understand that because that's
just kind of
extra and and I I want to ask let
representative seaworth ask his question
and and my question was very much in
line with I think where you're going um
and and we interrupted early on in the
presentation maybe you'll catch up with
this with the slides but what I'm
wondering is the Six Million as I
understand it it's a potential
savings and there is
a there's a path that will get that to
actual savings to the state and if I
could get an idea of what's missing
between here and then and how we get
there and I'd like to understand that so
I exactly what you're saying I want to
turn the potential savings we have on
the table to what is that a couple years
from now in terms
of savings that more than pays for what
we're doing to get them so so this is
just new information to me I don't know
how I missed her $6 million
recommendation but but if if you if you
uh I before we end yeah I would like to
understand what the form of that
recommendation
was who received that recommendation and
what we think the perspectus is on those
recommendations being accepted and
converted into savings right right do
you want to do that now or do you want
to get into the rhythm of your
presentation I can I can attempt to
answer it uh I can attempt to answer it
but then I I'll get back to the
presentation um We examined so part of
prescription drug pricing pbms negotiate
rebates um and and after the fact after
you do all the spending you get some
form of rebates back and it lowers your
net cost or that produces your net price
rebates are very secretive they are
confidential they are privately
negotiated between manufacturers and
pbms we at the pdab don't have access to
those rebates nobody is sharing that
information with us but we are trying to
get there and we're trying to analyze
bending by looking at the net price okay
so we did an analysis that looked at
estimated estimated what our current
rebate capture is for just 10 drugs that
were negotiated by Medicare um these are
the first 10 drugs that Medica Medicare
because Medicare can now negotiate a
limited set of prescription drug prices
so so I'm and so I'm confused the focus
of the PAB is to save State payers money
you referring to a federal program I
don't I so I'm I'm I'm I'm confused by
the jump yeah so Medicare operates just
similarly to how we operate in at the
state level with commercial plans so
Part D is a commercially administered
plan it is subsidized by the federal
government but they also use pbms and so
the secretary was uh barred from
negotiating up until last year and
starting with 10 drugs and so so now all
of those plans benefit because now they
have negotiated prices and those are
known net prices we have no other
Benchmark to know if what we're paying
is more or higher than what we should be
paying and so when we looked at what
negotiated priced in Medicare get which
is now public and they are increasing
the number of drugs over time we can
then say this is what we're missing out
on by not leveraging those rates and so
this was in our first attempt we
identified 6 million just on those first
10 drugs that are some of the highest
cost drugs to the state plan to local
plans and yes that's that is a an
instructive Benchmark um and we're
hoping that over time as those savings
get larger we can hopefully have plan
sponsors come together and figure out a
way collectively that we could negotiate
those rates um it was contemplated at
the federal level that you know states
in the commercial Market would have
access to those negotiated rates but
that was not enacted unfortunately but
we have opportunities at the state level
to think creatively about how we could
do that um and so that's where our
savings estimate came from so so to
summarize I think you're looking at the
example of Medicare seeing those 10
drugs seeing the the change in the
pricing you think we can take that uh
military term in Intel and convert it to
our Medicaid and other state purchasers
so that they have a road map to
achieving equivalent savings at the at
the state purchasing level yes all right
yes yeah and you know there there
international benchmarks you know we
could we could sit here and say well
Germany only pays $10 but we pay $300
but it's probably unreasonable that we
would get 10 but this is a a closer
Benchmark to something that is real and
actual and and us-based and us-based
exactly so how do we communicate that to
the purchasers of New Hampshire drugs
that that and that's Das I guess
Corrections um you know other entities
within the state like uh you know Mr
Litman and Medicaid right and and
Medicaid Medicaid is a bit different
they have a different but but how did
the board communicate it to the
purchasers so they know the board has
made a
recommendation well we we estimated the
savings we have not recommended
reference pricing that's not a
recommendation that the board has made
um but we are building the evidence and
distri and we are demonstrating what the
savings could be and we are
communicating it um by sending it to
them by alerting them to what we have
found uh we have an advisory Council
that we established last year um that
does consist of the the unions the
department of administrative Services
doj HHS Medicaid um the Department of
Corrections uh ccsnh the community
colleges and the university system so we
do have feedback loops um we we only
established the advisory Council in
April in August um so many much of this
is being built as we're flying the plane
but um but that is how we have gone
about it thus far o okay so what I'm
thinking I'm hearing you say is that
you're using the Advisory Board to
communicate this potential savings and
you're doing it uh through formal
meetings of The Advisory Board that's
one you you haven't you haven't
documented it in official letter from
the the the
board to send the letter to like Mr
Arling house and say right we have we
haven't done that step but you've been
talking through the advisory Council
right exactly and and and if we wanted
if we wanted to we could um I I like
that idea um I mean you're you're on the
board I I I also think that's a great
idea um but we we haven't done that yet
no okay all right are there any
questions at this point or
what okay thank you Mr chairman so um
your presentation is very well put
together and you're sort of going
through it through questioning so I just
want to make mention of the fact that
the advisory Council of which you are
referring right is on page 12 and the
members on page
13 of your very well put together
handout so everyone can get a good grip
on where that advisory council is found
in law their terms their meetings and
the membership so you're already on page
12 this is amazing thank you I am thank
you sir yeah I don't want to skip seven
though um oh is that I'm sorry I'm sorry
to interrupt can we have him even if
it's quickly he highlights the highlight
of each page as we flip through I feel
like we have done ourselves a dis
service here I I disagree uh I think
this is uh compatible with other
presentations where uh we've asked them
um questions as they've gone through the
slide deck and uh we had one change uh
in that we needed to let Mr White leave
early I'm fine with that and you sorry I
didn't mean interrupt you
continue so I I think I think our
approach is consistent and I've been
trying to get back to to letting Mr
Williamson drive through his
presentation great and if I could make
the request that we may so you you mean
that sincerely that that's great that is
great because I would like does sound
like you think it's great I'd like him
to continue through because I feel like
as my original request at the top of the
hour was to do a a quick highlevel
explanation for new members that I feel
we we just haven't even got but at this
point I think next term when you're the
chair you can do that
all right um okay we're going to try to
let you get back through your
presentation but you've made some points
that I wanted to get clarified okay okay
great and I think those clarifications
has strengthened your case awesome great
thank you um okay so so slide two going
back to slide two um this is the mission
goals and objectives of the board um we
spent a lot of time last year developing
this um it was no small feat um but our
mission is to serve essential public
function by analyzing prescription drug
prices in New Hampshire and making
recommendations to public payers and the
legislature um and then you can see our
goals and our objectives um moving on to
slides three and four um you know Rising
prescription drug costs are a Statewide
issue that impacts the budget at every
level um so I need to ask you another
question though on page two the third
bullet protecting patient access to
essential prescription drugs to improve
is that is that directly related to uh
RSA 126 bb or is that an implied mission
that the board has adopted uh for
itself I I I just want to know the
distinction between what you're required
to do in law and what you you're
required to do because it makes
sense yeah yeah I I don't there's no
statute that says that right no but
there is one that talks about the
recommendations the second yeah that's
clearly in statute that we're supposed
to make CLE yes yeah yes sir and that's
why I was talking about that letter
because I think since that's in statute
we need a record of what recommendations
we're making so that that can be yeah
okay so so go ahead okay um okay so uh
Rising prescription drug caus a white
issue it affects public payers
businesses and households um according
to a recent new future survey 53% of
Granite Staters are worried about
affording their prescriptions and one in
four Granite Staters skip doses are
ration their medications due to high
costs state and local governments
they're under increasing pressure
prescription drugs are a major cost
driver in Medicaid and in public
employee health plans small businesses
they struggle to stay competitive as
health insurance premiums rise and it
makes it harder for them to hire and
retain workers um families are also
having to make very challenging
decisions um many Granite Staters are
forced to deplete their safe take on
credit card debt or delay necessary care
due to the high cost of prescription
drugs which we just we don't see as
sustainable um the cost Trends indicate
continued strain on our economy unless
we are able to take proactive measures
and so this is where the P dab comes in
um Slide Five I'll now walk you through
um some slides just to give you an
overview of our budget request and who
we are um let me flip to that real fast
so starting on page six um the
governor's budget maintains stable
funding it allows the board to continue
its critical work um our budget is
highly efficient total is $256,500
on all of this work um but despite these
limited resources the PAB is already
identified savings um which proves the
value of continued investment and if
your intention is to continue funding
the board and we hope you do um we did
distribute a technical amendment that
would uh continue the executive director
position um so the board would have
stable leadership and staff to execute
on its Mission and so by continuing to
fund the PAB we are signaling to Granite
Staters that we hear them and we take
their concerns seriously ly um moving on
to slides eight and nine um the board we
operate transparently all of our
meetings are live stream and open to the
public um we regularly engage
stakeholders across the healthc care
system um the PAB is comprised of
legislators Health economists
pharmacists lay experts which really
helps to ensure that there's a broad um
range of perspectives we have regular
meetings that um allow for that type of
stakeholder engagement and helps to
ensure that we stay ahead of emerging
affordability challenges um all of our
materials presentations reports all of
our decisions it's all publicly
available um and on our website um I'll
then jump to uh slide 10 we're going to
we're going to want to come back to
seven but keep going okay um you're fine
for now keep going I just don't want to
overlook seven okay I'll make a note of
it
um slide 10 that provides an overview of
the pabs authority
um in our reporting uh M uh chairman
Edwards mentioned you know our our
primary objective is making cost saving
recommendations to public payers in the
legislature um but this is some of the
the things that we're test with doing um
slides 11 through 14 as already made
mention uh it uh details The Advisory
Council so the stakeholder advisory
Council was established last year and it
ensures the board's work is reflective
of State leaders representing a diverse
CR section of state government that all
touch on prescription drugs in some way
um and the members really helped to
guide the work of the board and ensure
that key voices have a seat at the table
um moving on to slides 15 through 17
these slides are intended to provide you
with key insights that we uncovered in
our 2024 analysis as you can see the top
25 prescription drugs they're brand name
drugs and they accounted for 44% of
total prescription drug spending
revealing a small number of drugs are
driving increased costs and so
understanding these Trends is critical
for negotiating better rates ensuring
competition and protecting New Hampshire
taxpayers this year's report will
incorporate prescription drug spending
under the medical benefit which is a
growing area of concern that is highly
concentrated with high cost biologics
and provider administered drugs so so
spend a little time there for the
education of the members yes uh the
medical benefit how does that compare to
the to to what we're already looking at
we would all assume a medical benefit
comes from all Pharmaceuticals but
you're making a distinction here right
thank you um so we analyze prescription
drug spending under the pharmacy benefit
and Pharmacy benefits are typically
administered by entities called Pharmacy
benefit managers they are middlemen who
negotiate rebates in secret they have
their own pricing strategies it's often
very challenging to know what you're
actually paying at the end of the day
but the all of that is administered
under a PBM they have no fiduciary duty
so they have no fiduciary duty to the
employer to the plan sponsor they simply
administer that benefit and this is all
of the drugs that you would get at your
CVS your Walgreens all the retail stuff
the medical benefit is often provided
separately than the pharmacy benefit and
medical the medical benefit would
capture spending in hospital spending in
a under a bundled payment in Medicare or
um an outpatient facility all of those
types of drugs provider administered
drugs infusions IVs those types of drugs
it the medical benefit is this is
getting weedy but it's very complex in
the terms of how of the claims that are
coming in it's not just by NDC which is
typically how the claims come in under
the pharmacy benefit under the medical
benefit it's hipi both acronyms NDC NDC
is the National Drug code every
prescription drug has a National Drug
code it's an identifier for the drug
right and then um under the medical
benefit you have the healthc care
procedures codes hips um those relate to
procedures and then within them there
are certain prescription drugs for that
procedure that takes a more work and
effort but we we have done the crosswalk
and so we are we are incorporating that
spending under the pharmacy benefit I
mean under the prescription drug spend
for this um upcoming report um but they
those are kind of two different ways of
administering how we pay for
prescription drugs one really relies on
rebates that's the pharmacy benefit and
the medical benefit that's often paid
off of like the average sales price in
Medicare or something right okay um so
just moving on to our accomplishments as
I mentioned at the uh top of the hour uh
we identified $6 million in savings
using the Medicare maximum fair prices
as a benchmark um we also modeled
spending on Humira which only recently
had a biosimilar launch it in enjoyed
well over 20 years of patent protection
um and is still our number one top
spending drug even after bio simers were
introduced into the market and so that
led uh to legislation act that is active
in the house right now um that would
help to improve competition among
approved biosimilars which is a very
very expensive category of drugs um and
then we're in the process of vetting and
formalizing a recommendation for a
pharmacy first discount card um that
would be no cost to the state open to
all Granite Staters um and based on
Connecticut's experience we could save
up to about $240 per script um and with
how many people they have enrolled in
the program that's $1.23 million that's
cash pay that's people that are maybe in
a high deductible health plan or their
drug was dropped from their formulary
those it would help really benefit those
who are underinsured or uninsured were
on fixed incomes retirees those types of
Po so two question questions on this on
page 18 again for the education of folks
the distinction between biosimilars and
uh generics yes generics are small
molecule pills um so there are brand
name small molecule Drugs That's you
know Advil Tylenol um anything that's a
pill or a tablet is a small molecule
then biologics are large molecule drugs
those are provider administered IVs um
you can think of drugs like Kuda or Huma
those are biologics um they biosimilars
are you can think of them as the generic
to a biologic um they have a much longer
Market exclusivity period they enjoy
much longer terms of patent protection
and so and the litigation for biosimilar
entjer the market is a much higher bar
than what it is for generics so we are
we have not seen the entry or the
competition among biosimilars manifest
like they have for generics but we're
doing every thing we can at the state
level to help facilitate that and in
general is it easier to get information
on the generics than it is the
biosimilars or or what what what is
what's the source of our biosimilar uh
pricing yeah anything that would come in
through claims you know once once the
drug is approved um then it would either
be covered or not covered by a formulary
um and then we would be able to analyze
that spending we didn't have any claims
for any bio similar for Huma last year
but it was only introduced last we
analyzed 2023 data that's the only
complete most recent data we had last
year so this year's analysis we'll be
able to see or measure what was the
biosimilar uptake um but there are other
distortions within that market that may
limit competition but we for another day
referring to claims do you mean Medicaid
claims or also commercial claims the
commercial claims so the state and local
employee plans that we um are TK
providing recommendations to all of that
data is submitted to the all paer claims
database and so we leverage that
database for our spending analyses okay
and then the third bullet um sure
what department or how would the state
Implement that if that were to be uh
chosen would is there already like the
department of insurance or somebody
would receive this as a task to make
happen or would the how how would we
Implement that right I think that that's
that's a that's a question that we are
hoping to address in our upcoming board
meeting um we have had productive
conversations with the governor's office
she's vetting it she has her staff
vetting it um you know that could be
something we take on but it okay okay um
and then you know looking ahead you we
are eager to work with the legislature
and uh the governor on launching this
discount card for all Granite Staters uh
we'll continue to issue recommendations
on prescription drugs that may pose
affordability challenges we're
strengthening our inter departmental
collaboration to facilitate data sharing
minimize redundancies um and then we are
also help um exploring opportunities to
strengthen Pharmacy benefit manager
Contracting and transparency
requirements um so there's a lot of work
under way um we have really appreciated
the support chairman Edwards you have
been very helpful in establishing our
processes and policies and and getting
us to a place where we feel like we are
empowered to make these recommendations
um so I just want to acknowledge that
sure and and for the people who have
been tracking this for four years there
was some initial concern about
redundancies and I think in this last
year we've cleaned up some of the
redundancy issue by clarifying that the
board does not collect data and store
data it relies on existing procedures
and departments to do all of that and
that you submit sort of a data analysis
request instead of owning the data and
the risk associated with it so so that
was a huge concern about redundancy that
I think you could have shown as uh an
accomplishment yeah thank you I yeah we
we did go through that exercise last
year with the insurance department um
and presented that in December to the
HHS committee all right uh
representative Daniels thank you Mr
chairman how does this proposed uh
pharmacy discount card differ from
something like good RX or an a discount
card or any other on yeah that's a
really great question um so RX um not
many people know this but it sells all
of your data so every time you use your
claims they they package all that up and
they sell it to pbms they sell it to
manufacturers they sell it to
advertisers um so and they also charge
pharmacies every time they run that card
whether or not they that the patient
actually picks that prescription up the
pharmacy's getting charged with this
card it is state-backed it is
administered by Oregon and Washington
jointly it's overseen by public servants
it does not charge Pharmacy for every
transaction it is privacy first it does
not sell anybody's data um we would only
receive you know aggregate this is how
much we saved but we wouldn't even get
demographic data um they take privacy
very seriously and I think that is
reflective of our values here in New
Hampshire so that is how it
differs do all do all discount cards
work the same way um most of them work
like how good RX does yeah mhm and but
and you can go online you can go online
and can compare um the rates that you
would get under good RX and you can this
this card would be administered by array
RX that's that's the entity's name um
and so you can go in there um all
pharmacies are actually participate in
aray rx's network already in New
Hampshire we just don't haven't launched
that card we just haven't done it yet so
it's another tool in the toolbox for
consumers to help AFF their prescription
drugs particularly if they're changing
jobs or if they find themselves without
employment or living fixed income this
is just another way to help
them represent
tki thank you for taking my question um
I believe tomorrow the full house is
going to vote on House Bill 570 which is
sponsored by the chairman and there is a
committee Amendment I'm wondering if you
could speak to that and the impact of
that Amendment thank you right and and
be and before you do let me round out
your question please uh I submitted two
bills I I submitted HB 570 and HB
645 64 5 was much more procedural we're
also voting on it it it it was it was
kind of a deeper into how we do business
uh for the pdab and that came out of
committee 17 to nothing U so so I I
think that was good policy that we put
together with the help of uh The
Honorable Gary Merchant and others uh
and then
570 uh was a kind of a simple Bill to
change some definitions I think and the
committee decided that they would amend
it to repeal the pdab AL together so so
tomorrow it's it's like we have to
decide are we repealing or are we fixing
and and that and that's kind of what the
the the the bigger question is for
tomorrow and and now with that you you
know please answer your question on on
what you think about those yeah I'll do
the best I can um you're right we we had
two bills we um were hoping to pass
through the legislature thank thank you
uh representative Edwards and yeah the
amendment is unfortunate it passed out
um on party lines um we would we would
lose um one of the the only independent
Watchdog of prescription drug prices in
New Hampshire um all of this work that
we have put in to standing the board up
to modeling savings to building this up
over time tracking our spending making
recommendations even if we may not have
made a voluminous amount of
recommendations we are beginning to do
so when I have highlighted those here
today um we all the work that we are
doing to help launch a prescription drug
discount card all of that stops all of
this work stops we wouldn't have anybody
that is making recommendations to State
and local employee plans I would also
note that um there are two municipal
risk pools that are on the brink of
insolvency and this is a challenge that
we are working to to help but that
magnifies or shows just how big of an
impact Rising prescription drug costs
are on this state and the proposed
solutions would increase cost really
would increase property taxes um because
of the risk of insolvency and so if we
can help these plans get a better spend
or negotiate better rates uh then we can
help decrease that tax burden but
without it nobody nobody's there to step
in and perform that oversight function
or bring the transparency to the market
like we're able
to thank you very much you're
welcome so I I'll I'll I'll come over um
okay I going into today's hearing and
and the LA the last couple of months uh
talking with the the chair of the board
um I I tried to make it very clear that
uh the Investments that we've made into
the board so far I would consider in
financial terms to be sunk costs I'm not
I'm not interested in going back and and
reexamining all of that because I know
how we got there but but going forward
there's a couple of things there's
there's um 645 has a fiscal note that
adds about $100,000 a year and the
purpose of that 100,000 is so that the
board can uh establish and operate a due
process uh mechanism so that when the
board sends questions to the private
sector the private sector has an
opportunity to respond that that's in
645 and that's the fiscal note do you do
you so my question on this now yeah yeah
yeah is because we don't have any money
this year right uh would if if we were
to delay the board were to delay
um querying the private sector we could
defer the 100 ,000 needed to set up a
due process sure is so how how do you
respond to the idea that that when we do
see 645 right um that uh an amendment
might be appropriate to defer that you
we have to have it when the board starts
to ask the questions yes yes absolutely
great question glad you asked it um that
that was assuming um we were we would
have to add uh add additional Personnel
um I hadn't talked with the insurance
department um if we're able to establish
the m and work with um the insurance
department or any other state agency on
conducting a data call then we wouldn't
necessarily incur $100,000 we would
leverage their um their existing
infrastructure um but we don't have I'm
the only staff member and aside from all
of all the work I'm doing um I I it
would it was unfeasible to think that we
could do that un funded but with working
with the insurance department I think we
can do it um without adding costs okay
so I don't want to speak for DJ you you
think you could take that fiscal note
down to zero and therefore you could
start making queries of the private
sector while still creating a due
process challenge
absolutely all
right we when we if we get 645 we should
talk about that okay okay so so the
other second thing is so I was looking
at this as an investment of like $550
million over the two years and given
that there was a a thousand
excuse at least I didn't say billions
whoa I'm GNA be rich yeah 550,000 sorry
um so um so I wanted a clear business
case right so that we could demonstrate
to the public because we've got the
house position on on 570 is to repeal
the board right well so so so what I
think we need is a a really clear
business case to show how that
$550,000 would return a a rate of uh
would be there would be a return on that
investment sort of a classic ROI
analysis of this is what we're spending
here here is something that we think and
this will deliver so we can deliver this
at the end of this two-year
budget right um it we I think it's
important to remind the committee we
don't have enforcement Authority so
there's we can't force anybody to take
our recommendations um I provided
savings estimates we will continue to do
that Medicare is negotiating 15 more
drugs this year we'll do 15 next year so
that was 25 drugs this year that we'll
estimate savings on um and this is
stimulating a conversation about are we
over spending on prescription drugs and
if some so so I just need an Excel sheet
where you make a business case and I
know that you're not the one that makes
the decision but we need to be able to
demonstrate how we think we're going to
um make this investment
payoff so uh is are there questions over
here representative PR thank you so much
for recognizing me thank you for being
here um some of some of my questions
have been answered before but um I'm on
Medicare and I buy a
prescription coverage through Edna y do
they also sell my information to
pharmacies
and as as a l what whatever that uh sure
a discount card discount cards would do
that I I no Etna would not be selling
your data the V first pharmacy discount
card is not out yet no and it's not
insurance it's not Insurance okay yeah
and the second thing is uh the number
550 um 550,000 has been floating around
here but your budget for 2026 and 2027
is
256,000 per per year per year so you're
talking about 550 for two years yes okay
right right um and we we have
appropriate we have uh money for
contracts for pro program Services
65,000 which is um I'm not I'm not
convinced that we're able to get a
contract off the ground for that amount
but we are a lapsing fund so we didn't
spend 65,000 that goes back into the
state Coffer so that's even it could be
less and the third question I have is
you have approximated about $6 million
do in savings um
do you have the number of Gran estaters
that have participated so far in this
program no no no and there's no way you
can do that no we we were modeling the
savings based on the Medicare negotiated
prices compared to what the estimated
prices are that we're getting now but no
one is in that program their estimates
on how many Medicare beneficiaries are
benefiting um and we included that in
the report you you have yes we have
included that in the report the Medicare
Savings yeah and in this slideshow not
in the slide deck no could you uh just
give me that information that would be
very
helpful thank you
yeah other
questions
okay uh repes representative Nano yeah
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you uh we
we spoke in the hallway yes I way a full
disclosure before the uh before the
session so I'm going to build on I think
representative seaw Worth's question and
as well as uh representative priests so
what we've got here is a basically the
Six Million is a
theoretical number of potential savings
and so the question and I think it also
relates to what chairman Edwards was
saying I don't see you know what's the
mechanism for you being able to ident
identify how much of the potential
savings however you're you're defining
that that we're actually realizing and I
would imagine that U there's a
significant P I don't know what the
number is of uninsured or sure um uh
underinsured people and it's not clear
that how how you reach those people I
know you reach out to for example the
state employees unions and I guess and
provide them with yeah information
on uh affordability or where where the
cost structure is detrimental so and
then as a second question in in your
presentation package here you show a a I
guess a a calculated number of $241 per
scrip and uh I'm guessing and maybe you
can tell me where that number comes from
because I'm guessing that it's on the
really high price
yeah um prescription drugs but not
really a representative average of a
full spectrum of drugs that people use
sure surek um so for the first question
you know we are providing directional um
uh information that can point you
directionally to in foreign policies now
you all are the policy-making entity we
we are empowering you all with the data
we are empowering plan sponsors to go
back to their pbms and say well you know
the PAB model these savings and we're
not getting the best discount or why are
we not getting that price they they can
be they can go to their plan sponsor and
ask that we are empowering them to do so
um and then we are also we want to work
with all of you to figure out what is
the right mechanism we currently in
statute don't have that mechanism but we
are we would love to explore that and we
are we we are working um over time to
get there um uh your question about the
uninsured so our recommendations by
Statute um are for state and local
employee plans not
uninsured that has been so that kind of
limits our reach um and that's a that's
a policy decision but I think we would
we would also um welcome the opportunity
to help folks that are uninsured as well
but um that was the uninsured question
241 per script yes that um the card
saves on average about 80% for generics
20% for Brands um when I was talking to
Connecticut about their experience
they're seeing a lot of folks use it for
maintenance medications for chronic
conditions um often Medicaid doesn't
cover OTC or over-the-counter drugs so
there are Medicaid recipients that have
to go and use that card um to afford
their their prescription drugs um so
they are also hearing a lot from folks
with high deductible health plans that
they are using that card a lot for some
of their drugs that when they have seen
that it's gone um off their formulary so
I I don't have a specific names of the
drugs but I I those are hopefully can
give you a sense of who is using it and
for what reasons what kind of drugs a
quick
follow a quick okay so I am the the the
protocol is once you have the floor as
long as you're asking relevant questions
just have a conversation so keep going I
hope it's a relevant question but not be
able to tell so the savings and
everything the recently there was a you
know the a cut in what they're able to
charge for something like insulin yeah
which is a you know an ongoing cut so is
that reflected in or still something
that you're looking at so um so yeah the
insulin issue um that if everybody
remembers um three manufacturers
controlled insulin and over the period
of about a decade the price increased
600% um individuals were rationing in
insulin which is a life-saving
medication um due to a lot of public
pressure um a lot of states started to
cap co-pays on prescript on insulin
themselves um and so we have done that
in New Hampshire New Hampshire has
capped out- of pocket costs um and the
manufacturers again due to a lot of
scrutiny at the federal and state level
um they did voluntarily lower their
prices but that's not necessarily
reflected in this report thank you okay
okay I and I want to the point that was
uh made here on
um
645 expands the scope of what the pdab
can look at because we didn't have the
statutory authority to to get the
Department of Corrections money and I
think that was one of the things that uh
representative Merchant and I and
Senator uh Ros Rosenwald wanted to make
more clear so so with 645 we included
Corrections and to the extent that there
are other
categories we can always expand the the
the the scope if it's appropriate Absol
absolutely and and that's that's a great
point and with the with the ARR RX
discount card they also have a voucher
program um that is available to
correction facilities so that would give
folks that are re-entering the community
a voucher to help afford their
prescription drugs and ensure a
continuity of care and that's something
that we can look into and would be maybe
a future recommendation that we would
make all right so representative cworth
and then representative Stringham did
you still have a
question I I think I'll wait for now
okay thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
jump back to the
$65,000 contract it sounds to me like
you've established a need you haven't
found a way to fulfill it and then
apparently you're somehow doing without
right now so I'd like to understand
what's going on and yeah yeah yeah um we
have yeah the line item for contract for
program Services um we since we only
have uh one staff member um additional
Consulting manpower to expand the bench
of folks that are able to help
operationalize the spending Target and
reviewing this data helping to make the
recommendations we we are looking to
procure expert Services um I some of the
feedback I've gotten from from folks
that would bid for this has said it's
far too low um so we may not be able to
actually get it out the door but um we
are working with the contracts
department and I would also note that um
we have the extra requirement of having
every contract approved by the fiscal
Committee in addition to GNC so unlike
every other board in the state we have
that additional requirement um so that
slows our ability down to actually get
it out the door or get the assurances
for folks to bid that you know it's
worth their
time yeah representative Stringham is
this later do you want to ask your
question now represent Daniels thank you
in addition to discount cards are you
also looking at other discount programs
like uh Cost Plus drugs that's a great
question um Cost Plus drugs um
established by Mark cubin um that's
largely a generic relabeling company um
that we could explore you know how plan
sponsors could work work more closely
with Mark Cuban's Cost Plus drugs
company um that's a different type of
reimbursement framework but I think it
shows that there is a problem with how
drugs are priced because he does show
very transparently what is the cost of
goods and how much is the drug or how
much is it going down over time whereas
other manufacturers don't do that and I
think it's a great effort in
transparency it doesn't solve the issues
that are facing the plans but it could
be one way we could help bring about
savings I think that's a great
idea all right um okay so uh we said we
would come back to page seven oh
sure
yep go ahead go ahead you
want I thought you had a question I'm
sorry
is yes sorry these are um explaining in
kind of more detail uh some of the line
items in our budget so there are General
administrative functions for for example
one state issued cell phone um that
helps ensure compliance um and
safeguards you know my email any any
sort of documentation um this helps to
uh underneath this umbrella you know we
are able to tap into Regulatory and
policy resources and also helps to
support um the software tools for data
analysis and Reporting and um another I
may have failed to mention this we are
an independent entity that is
administratively attached to DHHS so we
share and we we reimburse them for the
costs that we incur so um some of this
funding does help cover those costs and
so we don't have and we don't have you
know staff that we pay um then we have
travel and uh professional development
that allows for attendance at one state
policy conference um notably the
National Academy for State Health policy
um most recently I was nominated to um
to the academy actually and I'm on the
coverage cost thank you and I'm on the
coverage cost and value steering
committee you're probably on some cover
of a magazine
too um maybe one day um only if you
found me um and it allows for a meeting
with stakeholders um engagement in
National Pol policy discussions last
year I attended a legal conference in
Washington DC by nashby to help stay up
to dat on current um legal is 5,500 too
much I I've gone to lots of conferences
and I never spend anywhere near that I'm
a
$2500 trip guy yeah part of this is um
yeah the I think the for that conference
is something like $750 and then there's
you know airfare and hotel but it's also
instate travel out of state travel I I
meet with stakeholders I travel across
the state to meet with with folks all um
so that helps reimburse that um and then
we we touched on programmatic support
and we're currently at 65,000 a year for
contracts okay so this programmatic
support this is if you issue to the
Department of Insurance or request to do
some sort of new data query or to do
some data analis it for that if is that
what this is for I mean well it wasn't
intended for that it was intended for
you know Consulting expertise many many
departments boards they they you know
have contractors that assist and assist
with data analysis now if we needed to
do that then you know we could maybe
repurpose it for that function yeah okay
so so my thought has been that so far
we've been living off of the largess and
generosity of uh the other state
departments that that they've incurred
costs to support the establishment of
which no money has been transferred to
compensate them for it and so we have we
have we have anou that does cover the
but weent money um that would be a
question for Nathan how that
I I don't know how that gets done I
don't think we have but okay so um all
right so so that seems fairly reasonable
okay are there any other
questions
[Music]
uh Mr Merchant are do you do you have
anything to say to us I mean you you
you've got the most skin in this game
you've been doing this for over four
years is there anything you want to add
and the reason I'm belaboring this to
some people think I'm belaboring it is
because we have a
legitimate um effort to repeal the board
while at the same time we have a
legitimate interest in this being a
successful board right so this is just a
much bigger decision I think than you
know a half a million dollars over two
years it's a bigger decision but go go
ahead um The Honorable Gary Merchant
thank you Mr chair uh for the record my
name is Gary Merchant
um I'm the chair of the prescription
affordability board I am pleased that we
have executive director Kurt Williamson
here today to answer a lot of your
questions I would say we're at the cusp
of fundamentally do we try to continue
supporting the board with the work
that's been done and continue to work on
prescription Dr pricing affordability
for the residents of our state of New
Hampshire it's the one of the number one
issues in healthare cost we on the cusp
of making some really good
recommendations to different entities
we've put a lot we as a state we've put
a lot of effort in resources in getting
the board up to where it is today until
Mr Williamson came on board in January
of
2024 we couldn't really up stand up the
board so I think to your point chair Mr
chairman it's at the point of let's
continue down the the
road give the board the
opportunity to bring the recommendations
forward see where they go $6 million
potential savings with a lot of money a
discount card that could save our
citizens over $1 million a year a
voucher program these are only the
beginning of what we're finding so as we
go down the road and begin to analyze
the data we're finding more and more
things in the more we find the more we
can bring forward recommendations so my
thought
is let's not fix it but continue down
that road for the benefit of our
citizens also for most importantly our
taxpayers okay okay so when I ask for um
a business case analysis on the specific
recommendations that there there's
something to it I I and and we're asking
you to be a jack of all trades right you
you came to the board with a particular
background and
education you get asked to do a little
bit of everything well so if you if you
don't have any experience with business
case analysis i' I'd be happy to change
hats and help you as a board member to
get the right format together but but I
do think if this rolls into the Senate
that you you want to have much more
clarity about what the recommendation is
you and and and and and how we're going
to make money doing it so
um yes if I could Mr
chair the return on investment there's
two fold one is the fiscal side of it
the other social and trying to look at
it and saying what are we doing to help
our citizens in New Hampshire to make
drugs more affordable I totally agree
that we have to have a business case on
the fiscal side and that's critically
important but also Al not lose sight of
the fact that we're trying to help out
many folks in the state of New Hampshire
to make prescription drugs more
affordable the discount card for
instance may not save the state itself
directly money but over a million
dollars a year in savings to the
citizens of New Hampshire is a
significant amount of money um when you
start looking at Department of
Corrections so there things we can do
but I want to be clear with you folks
and everyone else yes we have to focus
on the fiscal
from an Roi point of view but not lose
sight of the fact is also societal
impact see I see that I hear you I see
that as a distinction without a
difference though I I think we can still
do a business case even if the state is
not uh directly benefiting from it
because this is all state money so if
we're improve if we're making things
better for the taxpayer through some
other mechanism I I I think it all all
we're talk all I'm talking about is
visibility and transparency so that when
people want to know exactly what the
benefit of this program is you can lay
out some some some hardcore numbers that
that that that's what I'm hoping you get
to and I think we're on the same page Mr
chairman and I want to say also
recognize um it wasn't so much in the
report but with your guidance and your
oversight that the issue of the data um
and having the ability for the board to
get available data and at that point in
time is the board not really being a
place to collect the data but being able
to work with other state agencies that
do collect the data so we don't have to
reinvent the wheel or build the
infrastructure is be able to have what
they call a data call to go to them and
saying this is the data we need you have
a something in place so we don't have to
again be redundant right so thank you
for that you're sure I know it's been uh
unpleasant because we've wanted to get
to the same point but we've been bumping
into each other the whole for four years
so uh representative Stringham well
first of all I want to say thank you for
all the hard work and and progress
that's been made I I was uh considerably
frustrated two years ago because going
through um line by line in details of
the budget uh we realized that
prescription drugs is a huge percentage
of the Medicaid budget and we spent
maybe all of 15 minutes on that uh out
of the weeks and weeks that we comb
through the budget virtually no uh
ability to impact what is prescribed or
how much we pay for it and um so you
know I I look at you know these last
three pages that are that are in there
that we have a
relatively um small number of drugs
costing 60,000 plus uh per patient a
year um you mostly in here we're looking
at the Medicaid budget um but
um uh you know one of one of the
frustrate one of the
uh frustrations if that budget continues
to grow and consume a bigger bigger
piece of the Medicaid pie uh you know
sooner sooner or later uh the pi is can
overflow the the pin uh the tan pan
thank you exactly right and and one of
the bills unfortunately the bill that
was amended to repeal the board would
have expanded um our authority to also
assist manid um and that was we we
thought we uh were supposed to look at
Medicaid but there's been differing
opinions on what the statute actually
said and this would have fixed that so
we could have helped address a lot of
that what is a growing um line item in
Medicaid and um a recent report by the
um by macpac which is the Congressional
um advisory Council that um advises
Congress on Medicaid they documented
that the cost of brand named drugs in
Medicaid doubled from 2018 to
2022 um these prices are growing and as
more Gene therapies are coming to Market
at over a million dollars each a lot of
these Target Medicaid populations um so
I think that is another area of growing
concern and will'll add to budget
uncertainty over time if if not
addressed but we are we are here to help
address them we are here to be a
resource for you and for other
legislators um and the public and public
payers so there there there's not a lot
in 570 um I mean the amendment obviously
is a big deal but but uh if 645
continues to
progress the legislative process will
have an opportunity to amend U 645 so
that we don't lose the good stuff that's
in 570 so so it's not done we're in the
middle of a we're we're still at the
relatively beginning phase of a process
so all right uh if you don't have if I
don't see any other qu questions and I I
I think have you wrapped up because I I
I need to ask the audience if there's
anyone in the audience if they have want
to speak you
guys thank you this went longer than I
anticipated thank you Mr chair all right
and the committee okay is there anyone
in the audience that wants to speak
anyone anyone
anyone okay so where are we at 2 o'clock
we're full finance committee uh down in
reps Hall um that that's expected to go
many many hours I wasn't able to verify
whether or not uh food is going to be
provided Ed if we go past 6 I think
that's a house rule that the speaker or
somebody can procure food if we go past
6 um and then uh Thursday what do we do
on Thursday Madam Vice chair that's a
house session that's the house session
so so our next time that we're going to
get together is
Monday has that been put in forward to
go into the house calendar yes it has so
you'll meet Monday at 10:00 a.m. uh for
bills and that fourth bill still needs
to be added um the uh Bill relative to
the county county payments so if if they
really want to keep that then I just
want input to it and I I'll I'll work
that out but if it gets into being no I
want it I I don't want to fight over it
I just have we've dealt with that issue
more okay yeah Madam Vice chair yes
thank you Mr chair so we during that
last presentation we were distributed
statutory language I'm not sure that was
discussed or if it should be discussed
but just thought I would bring that up
now since we were all given a hand out I
I think the value of the statutory
language was the was
the striketh through right the position
shall be effective the can I can I
address that yes sir um yes so um that
was included in HP 570 but this is a
technical Amendment um that for some
reason my position expires within 2
years of my hiring date so this would
just eliminate that 2year um term limit
essentially okay so I I think the the
people I've heard on this that
understand this better than me is is
that we should we should have I this is
a little personal um but but just
speaking at the policy level sure uh I
think it's true that all positions in
the state basically continue and your
position is is recorded as permanent as
is it not or is no no it's um you know
just like with any other position if if
the board's not funded I'm not funded um
so I'm not like permanently in statute
but but if if if it's continued to be
funded there's there's no ax getting
ready to cut you there is there is there
if that because yeah if that's not fixed
that yeah then I that is the axe yeah
okay so all right if if uh if we get
um one of those bills in here we'll keep
this in mind okay I appreciate it thank
you all right Mr chairman may I ask a
question yes ma'am Mr Ripple would it be
appropriate that this amendment be part
of House Bill 2 in order to ensure that
the position continues if it stays in
the budget it would be yep thank you
that's an option yep representative
priest thank you Mr chairman um just as
a comment thank you for everything
you've done I didn't realize you've only
been here for a year now and um it's a
large task and you're doing it very well
you and the board long way I appreciate
that would like to commend you and and
representative Merchant and the rest of
the members on the board uh for what
you've done so far well I really
appreciate and I really appreciate the
support of the legislature so thank you
all okay thank you okay well um I I
think that's it and so we'll go ahead
and adjourn today's work session see it
too